this is going to feel a little like deja
vu okay just now we introduced the idea
of arithmetic progressions aps we know
that they're just a specific kind of
progression where the progression for
this is very very like literally the
simplest rule you could possibly have
namely you start somewhere and you just
add just add numbers right so we define
them with all the three ways that we
knew before and using those three ways
we developed a test if you've got to
give an AP sorry if you've got a given
progression you can find out whether it
is an AP just by searching for that
common difference because that's what
makes an AP an AP so we're going to
focuses of the kind of progression than
we're interested in the geometric
progression which is what we would
abbreviate as our GP I've been advised
that this is a good color combination to
use so I'm going to stick with it now in
just the same way we're going to use our
three lenses for defining a progression
in the same order just like we did with
a page okay except for geometric
progressions what makes the geometric
progression special well it starts off
exactly the same way you define or you
set your first term to be a a for your
first value okay but here's the
difference instead of a common
difference that advances you from one
term to the next instead of adding the
same number over and over again to get
to the next term you multiply the
previous term by something you multiply
it okay so here's your previous term and
you multiply by now it's a lot of
difference anymore is it
right it's not like ah every time
there's a gap of two or three or
negative 8 right since it's not a common
difference since you're multiplying by
something we indicate this with the
letter R for common ratio okay so still
the same first value here or whatever it
is you happen to like and instead of a
common difference what makes a GP a GP
is that there is a common ratio
okay so that is how we advance her one
turn to the next it's very easy to list
out what the terms will be we'll start
with age just like we did before but the
next time will not be a plus something
it'll be a times R so it will just be a
R
what will the next term be a times R
again which is a R squared and then a R
cubed and so on okay so that's what a
list looks like for a GP what does the
general term look like well remember
last time we said the nth term it's
always going to have an A in it and we
notice that's the same here okay over
here we had some number of the common
difference being added on but I will
have something ever so slightly
different I have some number of the
common ratio being multiplied how many
see how there are no common differences
and then one and then two and then three
there's no common ratio and then one and
then two and then three
just like before it's always lagging
behind by one so let me n minus one okay
now tying all of that into one nice neat
ball if I wanted to test whether a
progression was geometric or not I'm not
going to use subtraction because
subtraction gets me to a common
difference instead of subtraction I'm
going to look for division right if I
divide subsequent terms then I will find
out whether there is a common ratio so
as an example if I went for something
like say
[Music]
okay so if I were provided with this
sequence how would I test whether it has
a cone ratio or not well first I need to
talk about wanting to label what these
terms are term one term to term three
and then I'm going to do a division just
like I did subtraction before okay I'm
gonna check term three on term to term
three on term - so if I'm proving I
can't skip this step here I need to
actually say do the substitution if I've
done my arithmetic right that's a half
yeah
that's a half so it's in my interest to
express this ratio as simply as I
possibly can now I just check the other
one turn to / term one which is 82 on 40
oh sorry wrong way around 41 on 82 order
is important which again is a half so
therefore the ratio that links the terms
is the same in other words it's common
okay so if there is a common ratio
it's a GP if there isn't a common ratio
if I find different values out of these
two workings here then it's not a GP no
problem maybe it's something else okay
most of the interesting stuff actually
happens with geometric progressions most
the interesting stuff but you will
encounter these in equal frequency at
least at the moment just like I
mentioned before you'll see this guy on
the reference sheet you'll also see that
one over there and it becomes pretty
important later on
okay so again simple idea but as you've
experienced over the last 40 minutes you
can come up with lots of interesting
applications of this kind of question
just from here and likewise over here
okay hmm
all right you mean can I do these upside
down hmm okay so that's a really good
question the question that I got asked
was can I do this in like commend
reciprocals can I do to 2 over 2 3 and T
1 over T 2 the short answer is yes you
can like it ends up creating the same
thing however I would avoid doing that
because what I'm searching for is this
I'm searching for are ya
now if I want to find R then you divide
a later term by an earlier term you
don't go the other way around
because if I did term 1 divided by term
2 I don't get ah I get the reciprocal of
our now if the odds are the same then
the one over ours will be the same but I
have an establish the same thing here
I've said look these two ratios are the
same because R is what it is in both
cases not something else related to our
but similar um there's a parallel to
this it's almost identical actually if
you think about similar triangles right
remember this if I say ABC X Y zip and
you prove that they're similar right we
know the corresponding sides in similar
triangles aren't ratio but think about
that sentence to yourself say it back to
yourself and think about how it relates
you corresponding sides in similar
triangles let me ask you see a and C are
they corresponding sides and similar
triangles and the answer is no they're
not they aren't they're not
corresponding to each other they're in
the same triangle right the
corresponding sides would be a and X
those two correspond I could say that
they're equal to be on Y now simple
arithmetic tells you that I could just
as easily have written this that's just
as that's numerically true but it
doesn't match up to your property right
these are not corresponding sides in
similar triangles any more than the this
is the common ratio so even though
numerically it ends up being the same I
think you should put it in the right